[Music]
Pope Francis told the people of South
Sudan the church has not forgotten
[Music]
thousands of people attended an open air
mass in the capital Juba to see the head
of the Catholic Church one last time
before he left for the Vatican
the pope once again called for peace
forgiveness and Reconciliation in a
country where many have been killed or
displaced by conflict
never lose hope and lose no opportunity
to build peace May hope and peace dwell
among you may hope and peace dwell in
South Sudan according to the United
Nations there are more than 2 million
internally displaced people in South
Sudan and another 2.3 million have fled
the country as refugees
those who attended the mass hope the
visit by the Catholic pope along with
leaders of the Anglican and Scottish
Presbyterian churches will make a
difference in this predominantly
Christian country I think Popes coming
to substance very appropriate given the
fact that for a number of years the
country has never been peace so we are
hopeful that he's coming
brings peace to South Sudan the message
that the pope is delivering
is quite important is coming to remind
Christian to love themselves based on
the Peace of Jesus Christ as the only
Prince of Peace South Sudan's president
salvakia promised to resume talks with
armed groups who did not sign the 2018
peace deal South Sudan broke away from
Sudan in 2011. then there was a Civil
War in 2013 with ethnic groups turning
on each other despite a peace deal
signing 2018 they're still violence in
parts of the country people here are
praying for peace
before coming to South Sudan Pope
Francis was in the Democratic Republic
of Congo a country also struggling with
conflict and Corruption his trip to
Africa was made to encourage politicians
to resolve their differences and work
towards peace
all people can do here is hope and pray
that happens haramatasa Al Jazeera Juba
Jack is a peace activist who was
detained in South Sudan and forced to
flee the country he explained why the
Pope's visit is significant
I have great hope for the visit of the
Pope and the other two religious leaders
the Archbishop of Canterbury and the
moderator of the Church of Scotland this
visit is very historic and we should not
see it from the lens of the leaders
alone we should see at what does this
mean for the people of South Sudan what
does it mean for the faith of Christian
faith in South Sudan and what it mean
for the Catholic church I do believe
this is a historic visit and it will
have a monumentous impact
among our people and in our country if
you would see the crowds that gathered
earlier today at the John Gran Mausoleum
and since yesterday when the two the
three leaders arrive in juga they
they're welcoming from the population
has just been absolutely amazing uh the
the the the number of the sheer number
of people gathered at John Gran Muslim
is something that has not happened since
our independent and I think this is
really where the impact is the impact it
should not be about the leader what
would this do for the leaders but what
it will do for the people now the pope
and the religious leaders by coming to
South Sudan at a time when the world
leaders have nearly forgotten uh the
suffering of the people of South Sudan
they have empowered our people and they
have powered their church leaders and I
think together the people and the choice
leaders United particularly the youth
and the women this will be the renewal
that the Holy Father has been talking
about since they embark on this trip